it's Monday [ __ ]
nice nice pilot to Bombardier
[ __ ] uncle Joey here come at you
direct it's Monday I don't give a [ __ ]
what the date is it don't matter it's
Monday that's all you need to know
you're coming out the box like [ __ ]
Steve Bay Miocic chick whatever it's
[ __ ] name is it don't matter
black people big people you could put a
building up against that [ __ ]
you know why it's gonna go down because
he don't give a [ __ ]
it's that immigrant [ __ ] mentality
your parents put in you as a young man
that's what we got over all these mother
[ __ ] way think we sketch from because
your parents tell you we came over here
and a [ __ ] 2x4 you better do
something with your [ __ ] life you're
not here to lose you played a win on a
[ __ ] daily okay when you were
10 you play tic tacs or whatever the
[ __ ] you playing for keeps now [ __ ]
that's a difference between life
yesterday and today you don't give a
[ __ ] you come out the box like a [ __ ]
man possessed and you put play that game
like if it's in your [ __ ] rules on
your turf I go back to 81 the Dallas
Cowboys gone into snowy Joey Ville in
San Francisco give him one enough half
points my point nobody gives you points
at home cuz it's always you got the
home-field advantage
that's how we start a Monday off all
right Joey what's with the [ __ ]
philosophical [ __ ] I turned on to
smoke let's smoke this [ __ ] with the
Larry oh geez still killing
[ __ ] we got the [ __ ] true OG
killing [ __ ] you know why they
call it true it's true sir
minute you smoking dope the next thing
you do what you really want to do suck a
[ __ ] [ __ ] to dick that's why they
call it truth serum but let's get down
if you came to Austin my heart goes out
to you you're the best [ __ ] audiences
I love your [ __ ]
I also want to thank my man Bobby
Sheeran crystal he proposed to her last
night at the [ __ ] fiasco I propose a
[ __ ] solid [ __ ] down in
Austin
Bobby Sharon and crystal I wish you all
the luck in the [ __ ] world you're
part of the church can you always will
be and I'm saying your [ __ ] family
and family to me means [ __ ] family
and I got the rest of these half of [ __ ]
these family get the [ __ ] out of here we
breathe for one another when you're in
the church you breathe for one another
you can't put that in your [ __ ]
vocabulary then stop talking to us cuz
that's how we go down I'm with you
you're with me and they want to be with
[ __ ] and bas Rutten h2o peace
ready to rock and roll let's try a
little bit this [ __ ] Larry on G and
see what we're standing for they don't
forget today podcast three o'clock
Tuesday night I'm shooting a show
Tuesday day so I don't know what's gonna
happen break we playing here by [ __ ]
here every gear changes saying if I
wanted to have a schedule I would have
[ __ ] got a day job anyway Thursday
when's that blast off the [ __ ]
Charlotte North Carolina ready to
[ __ ] Rupp
I'm there Thursday Friday and I think
the UFC's around the neighborhood
somewhere I'm Saturday I don't give a
[ __ ] I'll be throwing sidekicks and
doing spinning [ __ ] around houses on
my own I'm saying
but then again I want to thank cap city
let me listen 2018 imma [ __ ] around
okay I got my love self a little bit
like wat and [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
as usual stars edibles we thought
everybody smell everybody's [ __ ]
r-rated and everybody anybody who comes
into my shows get sniffed down by a dog
if the dog don't die I don't want you in
the [ __ ] show you know I'm saying
beside that it's Monday it's your
[ __ ] world don't take [ __ ] from
nobody alright whatever happened last
week happen last week can't do nothing
about just start it over today stick to
it and don't take no [ __ ] from nobody
who's at the end of the day dog they all
gotta suck it they always remember that
there might be criticizing you today but
but you stick with it you got true
belief in your heart by the end of the
[ __ ] day they will be sucking your
dick intended go your Luna not that way
complete gut theory or a secret that
didn't get my metal a Pingo ayah okay -
Latoya latina and I'm her son Tony
isopropyl evil have some DC metallic
gold sorry so I'm coming out a [ __ ]
box today like a [ __ ] you know
faking the injury I'm still [ __ ] you
up Tom Brady up damn you know if you're
gonna be white read the [ __ ] Tom
Brady story you gotta be white just like
him that's the last savage white man in
this [ __ ] world you don't give a [ __ ]
jack but he stuck his finger up [ __ ]
Judy [ __ ] [ __ ] yes play a half time he
came out through those [ __ ]
touchdowns that's how you do it jack you
gotta get out there and [ __ ] bang it
on a daily I don't give a [ __ ] what ever
happened yesterday happen yesterday
today's the day go out there don't take
[ __ ] from nobody you got a dream [ __ ]
live it live it and then they don't want
to be a part of your dream [ __ ] throw
them off the railing who gives a [ __ ] at
the end it's you against the [ __ ]
world you follow me and then it's you
against you so you got to [ __ ] Wars
you're fighting at one time smoke a
little reefer write your notes until
you're twenty two push-ups and tell the
world you know what you better [ __ ]
hide and camouflage cuz I'm coming for
you [ __ ]
that's all you need to [ __ ] know
today nobody's gonna stop you don't give
a [ __ ] and when the odds get heavier
than shoe you get [ __ ] heavier you
follow me nobody had more odds against
in the net will [ __ ] steep in Miocic
nobody thought he had a chance against
[ __ ] Godzilla but listen you figure
out a way you strap a pair on you look
it straight on and you don't give a [ __ ]
and those are the people that [ __ ]
succeed cuz they don't give a [ __ ] don't
worry about this going about hillary
don't worry about trump don't worry
about your uncle who gives a [ __ ] about
this is it's all about you at the end
there then when you're dead it's you in
that casket by yourself do the [ __ ]
Mac live your life a sling dick and go
for it and if anybody tries to get you
away push him up
take the head off the pipe and blow
smoke in his [ __ ] face
you follow me beside that you got it
down tonight in three o'clock Churchill
what's happening now Thursday Friday
Saturday comedies on Charlotte
if you ain't there you're [ __ ]
slippin Thursday nights when we
sacrifice a [ __ ] human being it's the
cheapest ticket get down there Thursday
night we rock we roll we take [ __ ]
pictures we jump up and down and that's
it as that listen nobody could stop you
tell you that didn't get my might tell I
ping there you know why cuz uncle Joey
sent you and let him know that when you
walk in before anything uncle Joey sent
me that's the state of mind I mean I'm
not [ __ ] around today so have a good
day god bless you stay black and I'll
see you [ __ ] tonight three
o'clock tip top Magoo ready to [ __ ]
throw Heat all right they get on the
month